faciliter l'achat local c'est le but
d'une toute nouvelle plateforme amazon
québec qui est lancée par isabelle
chevalier et georges karam des
entrepreneurs qu'on peut voir à
radio-canada dans l'émission dans l'oeil
du dragon il avait les chevaliers
bonsoir bonsoir
peut-être les liens ben oui ça va bien
vous même ça va bien vos affaires vont
relativement bien je suis dans votre
compagnie et vous oui bon fait partie
donc des services essentiels donc on a
eu la chance si je peux dire de ne pas
fermer les bureaux on est en télétravail
mais la production continue d'ailleurs
les saluts ils font un travail
extraordinaire
ils tiennent le fort et puis avec toutes
les mesures de plus on met en place
jeudi probiotiques contre les gentils
effectivement vos produits il ya quatre
pièces voilà parlez-nous un peu de votre
de la plateforme qui lançait aujourd'hui
en quoi ces différents puis on va
revenir sur la plateforme là en quoi
c'est différent du panier bleus oui
alors maso quebec.com c'est une façon
pied transactionnel donc en fait c'est
un lieu où va pour découvrir des
produits locaux donc c'est vraiment
juste des produits québécois on peut
acheter donc je pense que c'est ça qui
est le principal mans il ya d'autres
différences mais en gros c'est qu'on
peut vraiment acheter dans le magazine
on cherche un chandail une chaise
importer on l'achète directement donc
sur la plateforme est donc est-ce que
c'est complexe d'avoir bâti sa 1re
répertoire mais un répertoire où on peut
aller cliquer lui dire qu'on achète
oui c'est ça en fait c'est vraiment
toutes sortes de compagnie dans
différentes catégories
et on peut donc acheter on peut faire
aussi la classification oms la recherche
par région on peut le faire par marque
et on peut le faire par item catégorie
que l'on peut se promener donc selon
l'objectif de tout ça c'est vraiment de
rendre l'achat local faciles 5
parce que c'est pas nouveau qu'on parle
d'achats loquace des années qu'on parle
d'achat local ou mais pourquoi est-ce
que c'est pas devenu quelque chose de
usuel de deux quotidiens pour la
majorité des consommateurs
ça c'est pas vraiment facile de le faire
puis on a tout
j chargé des enfants des jobs et pour
rendre ce simple c'est ça qui va faire
qu'on va le faire de façon régulière et
ses objectifs facile de trouver
exactement ce qu'on veut quand on dit on
veut acheter quelque chose qui est créé
qui conçut au québec qui peut être
fabriqué au québec ou ailleurs c'est pas
toujours simple mais les gens pour
souvent la question du prix est-ce que
c'est moins cher de magazines et là tu
où est-ce que des rabais des aubaines en
fait toutes les compagnies d x offre d
aubaine donc ça revient vraiment aux
marchands au premier sens à faire leur
aubaine épuisant non il y en a beaucoup
on a même une section soldent donc aux
ben oui et les gens peuvent aller donc
là et tous les produits qui se
retrouvent dans cette section le sont
soldés mais après les commerçants ont
certaines soldes sur certains items et
mais après le par rapport au prix c'est
une une préconceptions si on veut les
gens pensent ce facilement mais ça
dépend si on le compare à quoi la chaîne
locale surtout au début était vraiment
plus artisanal et en petites quantités
si on regarde de plus en plus de
compagnies qui font des grandes
quantités de produits dont on arrive à
avoir une certaine offre compétitive et
puis aussi faut voir qu'est-ce qu'on
compare le ya combien d'entreprises sur
le site web
kan lors on a je pense 6000 quelques
produits qui sont live on a plus de 5000
compagnie qui se sont inscrits
maintenant c'est pas encore toutes les
compagnies convoi le présentement ce
site alors ya beaucoup de travail qui se
fait dans l'arrière du site évidemment
remporter toutes les compagnies et les
fiches clients les envoyer plusieurs
items donc on est en train de les faire
alors ce que vous voyez c'est déjà quand
même une bonne qualité ainsi peut-on
d'avoir mis ça en place
mais cessez le feu ben en fait c'est
ouvert à toutes les compagnies qui sont
québécoises évidemment et puis aussi ça
c'est un point évidemment des compagnies
qui sont québécoises que les produits
sont conçus ici et on a développé deux 2
car il y en a un qui est bleu foncé
qu'un bleu pâle pour pouvoir faciliter
aux qu'au niveau du consommateur ce
choix là dans l'achat local et qu'il ya
des produits qui va avoir un coeur bleu
foncé et ça ça va
pour des produits qui sont
majoritairement conçu et assemblé au
québec ou utilisant des matières
premières du québec et le club le passé
des produits qui sont assemblés ou avec
des ingrédients ou des matières
premières qui viennent majoritairement
de l'étranger mais qui demandent
toujours des compagnies québécoises avec
une conception québécoise est ce que
fait homme pour but de vivre
temporairement pendant la crise où vous
souhaitez que ça reste en fait l'idée de
notre plateforme quant à george et moi
on n'a pas assez ça ça vient d'avant la
crise
en fait c'est parce qu'on est impliqué
donc avec les dragons voit beaucoup de
deux pme mais aussi avec l'école
d'entrepreneurship de beauce qui avec
d'autres d'autres organismes parce qu'on
est proche de plusieurs pme et c'est un
besoin qui revient souvent mais comment
ce qu'on fait pour faire connaître nos
compagnies qui sont des petites
entreprises on peut toujours un site web
puis de payer du sos même de faire sa
place sur le web c'est pas toujours
évident là ça se trouve être un
rassemblement pour les frères et ionix
une des choses qu'on regarde aussi sur
le site c'est qu'on voit plusieurs
vidéos d'entrepreneurs parce qu'on veut
pas juste découvrir le produit avec un
prix mais l'individu qui est derrière
souvent la personne qui leur font du à
la démission clair et c'est ça qu'on
veut connaître et quand on connaît le
fondateur sa raison pourquoi ils ces
partis en affaires seront tous en amour
avec et on a envie de supporter et ça je
pense que c'est un élément aussi clé
dans ce mariage mais au niveau québécois
de découvrir toutes mais on a vraiment
des petites perles mais c'est de les
rendre visibles et puis justement de
délits sportif voilà ça s'appelle
mazzone québec s'est déjà en ligne
isabelle chevalier bonne chance merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup et plaisait